[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai le cœur qui bat très vite
et du coup je vais me rappeler que peu
importe ce que vous pensez de MOI que ça
vous mette en colère que vous ayez des
jugements sur moi que vous trouvez ça
nul
c'est ok
ma valeur de défend pas ce que vous
pensez il faut que j'y crois
de quoi est ce que je peux vous parler
ce soir qui peut créer des jugements bon
c'est clairement
il y a un indice
ça résume en un mot une étiquette je
suis polie amoureuse
ça veut dire que j'ai plusieurs
relations affectives
en même temps
et que tout le monde est au courant
d'ailleurs j'ai deux
amoureux ici ce soir
Raphaël et
le couple c'est ma passion
j'en ai fait mon métier je suis
psychologue et coach spécialisé dans
l'amour les relations la sexualité
j'ai été en couple toute ma vie d'adulte
monogame puis en couple ouvert et
maintenant polyamoureuse
et au travers de toutes ces explorations
il y a une question qui reste pour moi
c'est comment rester en amour
c'est pas parce que je crois que la
longévité c'est un marqueur de succès
dans les relations il y a plein
d'histoires de très longs couples qui ne
me font pas du tout rêver non c'est
plutôt comment je reste en amour avec
moi-même dans ce lien comment je ne me
perds pas comment je reste en amour de
l'autre et comment ce lien continue de
s'enrichir et de nous épanouir sur le
long terme
et le polyamour il m'a aidé dans cette
quête il m'a fait réaliser des choses
c'est pour ça que je vous en parle ce
soir
la grande différence entre le polyamour
et la monogamie c'est qu'on va assumer
et agir sur nos désirs sexuels et
romantiques
alors ça en soi malheureusement c'est
pas vraiment nouveau on connaît tous des
histoires d'infidélité non la vraie
révolution c'est que cette fois-ci on en
parle
toutes les personnes impliquées sont
consentantes et on essaye de faire ça de
manière éthique
dans mon monde par exemple
je peux aller une soirée avec mon mec et
rencontrer une de ses copines et on va
peut-être danser ensemble probablement
se demander comment ça va est-ce que tu
as besoin de quelque chose
dans mon monde le soir du nouvel an je
peux aussi envoyer un texto à Habibi
pour lui demander du soutien parce que
je suis en train de flirter avec un mec
et j'ai peur de l'inviter chez moi
et dans mon monde je pouvais
où je gère la jalousie mes insécurités
parce que j'ai un partenaire qui a un
date qui me challenge
si pour vous le polyamour c'est une
hérésie ça n'a pas de sens je comprends
la première fois comme on a parlé j'ai
dit
moi je pourrais jamais partager mon mec
voilà donc je suis là maintenant devant
vous clairement n'a jamais dit à jamais
tout ça tout ça
donc je comprends que ça paraisse
bizarre et
parfois impossible de polyamment
et mon envie ici c'est pas du tout de
vous convaincre de devenir polyamoureux
non non je pense vraiment pas que ce
soit fait pour tout le monde
par contre depuis que j'ai découvert la
non monogamie éthique j'ai une idée en
tête que j'ai envie de créer sur tous
les toits
cette idée c'est
je pense que tout le monde devrait
parler de son désir sexuel pour d'autres
personnes à son amoureux ou son amoureux
et je pense même que ça peut être bon
pour votre relation
j'entends déjà vos objections mais à
quoi ça sert on va que faire du mal à
l'autre mais quand tu aimes vraiment
quelqu'un tu ne vois que une personne
etc etc
je veux juste apprendre une respiration
ça va durer 15 minutes c'est mon univers
et vous verrez bien à la fin si ça vous
parle ou pas
j'ai pas essayé de démontré si oui ou
non l'être humain peut avoir du désir
pour plusieurs personnes en même temps
je pars du principe que si on nous
l'interdit
c'est bien parce que ça arrive
et du coup je préfère y faire face
je vais vous partager mes trois raisons
pour lesquelles je pense que c'est bon
de parler de son désir sexuel pour
d'autres à son partenaire
la première raison c'est pour éviter des
souffrances
inutiles
on vit dans une société qui est monogame
donc la norme c'est l'exclusivité
sexuelle et affective
si tu n'as jamais de désir pour d'autres
personnes tant mieux tu es dans la norme
ta vie est plus douce
mais qu'est-ce qui se passe pour toutes
les personnes qui ne fonctionnent pas
comme ça qui sont peut-être très
amoureux amoureuse de leur partenaire et
quand parfois ils vont à une soirée
il y a un crush sur quelqu'un quand même
ça réveille quelque chose
ou parfois peut-être que tu tombes
amoureux de quelqu'un d'autre
comment on gère ça
ce qui va souvent se passer c'est qu'on
va rentrer dans une boucle de doute de
honte
d'isolation c'est à dire que quand je
commence à sentir ce désir pour
quelqu'un d'autre parce que oui ça m'est
arrivé quand j'étais monogame
je me dis non mais c'est bizarre quand
même je devrais pas ressentir ça est-ce
que ça veut dire que du coup je suis pas
amoureux amoureux pour moi amoureuse de
cette personne
et si ça continue au bout d'un moment je
vais ressentir la honte
je dois vraiment être une mauvaise
personne pour ressentir ça en fait
pourquoi est-ce que je peux pas être
comme tous les autres et avoir une vie
plus simple
et la honte en effet c'est qu'elle nous
isole on reste dans nos peurs dans nos
jugements dans nos croyances
et du coup ça va créer un effet vicieux
ou je vais créer de la distance avec ma
partenaire parce que je suis dans ce
tourbillon de honte
la partenaire va le ressentir
potentiellement ça va créer de
l'attention et ça va venir conforter
confirmer l'idée que bah oui il y a un
problème dans notre couple quand même
et alors là il y a des personnes qui
vont jamais passer à l'acte mais elles
ont vécu tous ce moment quand même assez
désagréable sans pouvoir le partager
avec leur partenaire
et puis il y a ceux qui passent à l'acte
qui vont vivre une infidélité
et là il y a tout le coup qui vient avec
la culpabilité et ce que je le dis je le
dis pas et si jamais c'est révélé si le
truc la prend comment est-ce qu'on
réussit à réparer cette blessure de
trahison
et moi quand mon partenaire Raphaël
avoué ses infidélités je suis tombée des
nues je me suis dit mais c'est pas
possible on s'aimait tellement on se
disait tout comment ça a pu nous arriver
est-ce que je dois du coup réécrire
toute notre histoire d'amour
j'aurais aimé avoir d'autres croyances
sur l'amour l'infidélité pour que ce
soit plus doux à ce moment-là pour moi
et je vous invite à imaginer un autre
scénario
si on vivait dans un monde où quand on
rencontre quelqu'un ça se passe bien on
est vraiment amoureux on pouvait en
parler de ces choses là par exemple
mon amour je t'aime je suis trop bien
avec toi j'ai vraiment envie que ça dure
longtemps entre nous du coup viens on se
prépare aux obstacles de la vie c'est
fort probable qu'à un moment donné toi
au moins on ressemble du désir pour
quelqu'un d'autre
et j'ai pas envie que ça nous fasse peur
j'ai envie qu'on s'en parle
j'ai envie qu'on soit uni et souder
là-dedans
si c'est ça les bases de votre relation
ça va permettre à votre partenaire de
venir vous voir quand effectivement ça
arrive il va pouvoir vous raconter que
elle est toute émoustillée à chaque fois
qu'elle parle avec la nouvelle nouvelle
d'armée de votre club préféré
et vous pouvez l'accueillir avec
enthousiasme et curiosité ah ouais mais
qu'est-ce qui te plaît chez elle
qu'est-ce que ça réveille chez toi
[Musique]
et alors on n'est pas obligé d'agir sur
nos désirs
mais leur faire de la place les assumer
les honorer
ça fait qu'on se connaît mieux
et qu'on permet à l'autre de nous
rencontrer aussi vraiment
et de manière collective ça fait qu'on
peut commencer à changer les croyances
sur l'amour et je pense que ce serait
plus plus agréable de vivre dans un
monde où c'est pas parce que on a du
désir pour quelqu'un d'autre que ça peut
nécessairement dire qu'on est plus
amoureux qu'on n'est pas engagé
deuxième raison de parler de ses désirs
c'est pour rester aligné avec sa vérité
sa joie sa vitalité
au début d'un couple il y a tout ça mais
assez souvent on voit que ça s'éteint au
bout d'un moment
il y en a de moins en moins
pourquoi
ma théorie c'est que
c'est souvent lié au fait que on a peur
du conflit on a peur de la différence
donc mon idée c'est qu'on va éviter ça
on en parlant justement
je sais pas pour vous mais moi quand je
rencontre une nouvelle personne je suis
un peu stressée
et quand on demande tu veux manger quoi
ce soir pour dîner je réponds assez
généralement comme tu veux comme tu veux
vraiment je veux pas déranger avec je
sais pas mon envie de carbonara comme si
vraiment ça allait causer la troisième
guerre mondiale
bon pour un repas c'est pas très grave
mais si toute ma relation je la base là
dessus et à chaque fois
comme tu veux comme tu veux au bout d'un
moment à force de me sur adapté de Me
diminuer
je vais devenir l'ombre de moi-même
[Musique]
et même si
c'est pas toujours ça qui arrive dans
cette extrême je pense que vous pouvez
vous reconnaître dans ce mécanisme et
donc il y a l'adaptation à notre
partenaire mais il y a aussi
l'adaptation aux normes sociales c'est à
dire que et tout un tas d'attente quand
tu es en couple
quand tu es en couple tu deviens le plus
un officiel de ta personne tu dois aller
à tous les événements où il y a un plus
un même quand ça te fait un peu chier
quand tu es en couple tu es censé dormir
dans le même lit que ta partenaire ou
ton partenaire même si en fait il ronfle
et je remercie polyamour parce qu'elle
m'a vraiment aidé à sortir de toutes ces
normes et à me poser des questions sur
les qu'est-ce que moi je veux vraiment
en fait
et du coup récemment j'étais dans une
situation qui m'a un peu challenge
savoir ce que je veux vraiment ça a pas
toujours été facile pour moi
et j'avais invité la Bible à passer une
semaine de vacances avec ma famille il
avait dit oui j'étais trop contente plus
la date se rapproche et plus je me dis
en fait c'est pas complètement juste
pour moi j'ai envie d'un cocon j'ai
envie d'un truc plus sécurisant pour moi
et je sens qu'en fait j'ai envie de le
vivre avec Raphaël
j'ai ressenti de la honte de la gêne de
la culpabilité mais je me suis dit non
non ça vaut le coup j'ai envie d'être
honnête j'en ai parlé à Habibi
qui m'a partagé sa tristesse la
déception mais il m'a aussi célébré dans
ma capacité à changer d'avis et à être
honnête avec lui
j'ai passé les vacances avec Raphaël et
mon lien avec la bibi est devenu
d'autant plus fort parce que maintenant
il sentait qu'il pouvait me faire
confiance dans mon oui dans mon nom et
le fait que je me suis adaptée pas à lui
tout le temps
vous allez me dire ok ok on peut
peut-être parler de nos désirs c'est
important etc et pourquoi est-ce que tu
veux qu'on parle de nos désirs sexuels
ça fait quand même beaucoup quoi pour
d'autres personnes en plus
mais en fait je crois que c'est
tellement difficile de remarquer tous
ces endroits où on fait des petits
compromis parce qu'on se dit non mais
c'est pas très grave c'est pas grave si
je mange pas mais pas de carbo ce soir
c'est pas grave si le film qu'on regarde
c'est parce que je préfère et à force de
faire ça
on s'étend
et donc je pense qu'il faut pousser le
curseur et aller jusqu'à ce tabou c'est
interdit et travailler à assumer le fait
que bah oui parfois j'ai dû désir pour
d'autres personnes et je pense que si on
arrive à être honnête à ce point le
reste sera plus facile et mon autre
envie
sur pourquoi est-ce que j'ai envie qu'on
parle de ça c'est que j'ai envie qu'on
casse les tabous autour de la sexualité
j'en ai marre que on n'ose pas parler de
ses parties intimes faut pas dire le mot
et que l'énergie sexuelle est vu comme
souvent quelque chose de un peu honte
quand même alors c'est OK si c'est
dirigé vers l'amour la romance mais si
tu as eu 50 partenaires dans l'année
c'est moins bien quand même alors que
l'énergie sexuelle pour moi c'est cet
élan vital c'est ce truc qui me donne
envie d'aller vers d'aller croquer la
vie d'aller en fait ça me permet d'être
connecté à ma boussole interne
de savoir faire quoi j'ai envie d'aller
faire quoi mon comment est-ce que je
peux grandir évoluer
donc je vous ai j'aimerais que vous
imaginiez un amour qui célèbre vos
désirs vraiment qui vous encourage dans
votre extension qui ne vous limite pas
avec des phrases du type mais moi de
toute façon je te connais par cœur
d'où tu me connais par cœur en fait moi
je sais pas qui serait dans une semaine
dans 10 mois dans 15 ans laisse-moi te
surprendre
j'aimerais qu'on soit plus humble face
au mystère que représente notre être
aimé
et moi en amour comme ça j'ai envie de
le cultiver j'ai envie de le nourrir
parce qu'il me donne de l'espace pour
grandir
on arrive à ma troisième raison vous
pouvez croire que je suis là avec ma
jupe à fleurs à parler d'amour libre en
fait la sécurité je m'en fous
détrompez-vous j'ai un petit coeur
anxieux et j'ai envie de créer des
relations vraiment solides
mais qu'est-ce qui fait de la solidité
pour moi c'est notre capacité à rebondir
j'ai l'impression qu'on se focalise
beaucoup trop sur des marqueurs externes
de sécurité ces marques d'engagement du
type ah bah ça fait longtemps qu'ils
vivent ensemble quand même brisant
acheté un appart et puis là ils se sont
pacsés et là ils vont faire un enfant
alors certes tout ça c'est des trucs
très importants
mais est-ce que vraiment c'est une
garantie de la vitalité et de la joie
que ressent ce couple à être ensemble
pas nécessairement je connais des gens
qui vivent ensemble depuis longtemps et
qui en fait sont des sortes de coloc
ou même ils sont devenus des étrangers
en fait ils marchent sur des œufs à
chaque fois qu'ils sont dans la même
pièce parce qu'ils savent plus parler
moi ce que ce à quoi j'aspire c'est une
sécurité qui vient de l'intérieur
savoir que je peux me déposer que je
peux parler de mes émotions que je vais
pas être manipulée ou blâmé pour ce que
je ressens que l'autre a une capacité
d'introspection et qu'on va prendre du
recul sur ce qui nous arrive et comment
on y arrive
bah on essaye en testant en apprenant on
a besoin de se muscler en fait là dessus
et c'est pour ça que j'ai envie de
recevoir des petits chocs régulièrement
[Musique]
pas des trucs énormes qui me
traumatisent mais juste c'est rappel que
ben oui en fait mon partenaire parfois
il a envie d'être ailleurs il ne
m'appartient pas il a des passions qui
sont différentes des miennes
et plus je me rappelle ça et plus je
travaille le fait que ok parfois il part
mais aussi il revient
on apprend en faisant ce soir mes deux
partenaires se rencontrent pour la
première fois
j'ai clairement un peu peur ça se trouve
ça va être gênant ça va pas quoi dire
mais on est tous les trois alignés avec
cette vision
et donc même si ça se passe pas au top
on va apprendre et la prochaine fois que
ça se passera mieux
je vais finir en vous disant que le
monde il est pas binaire vous n'avez pas
à choisir entre monogamie et polyamour
entre sécurité et liberté tout ça c'est
sur un spectre
et vous pouvez
choisir ce que vous voulez en termes
d'ouverture pour créer votre relation
sur mesure
je vais juste vous rappeler que si le
début d'une relation c'est aussi
excitant c'est bien parce que il y a de
l'inconnu
merci pour votre écoute
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]